Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
authored by
in the 19th book or in some versions.
The 18th book,
[Silence]
I'm trying to choose.
It's you know it's so many nice
narrations.
[Silence]
Islam.
Here
we have a narration
and it's actually
and it's actually a
a an explanation
offered to us by Abi by Abu
Now there's not a lot of narrations
from Abi
with respect to him
explaining verses of the Quran. This is
rather unusual
because Abu
was more specialized in hadith. Because
he had memorized so much from the
prophet.
Wasam due to his diligence and also that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
specifically chose him to be the
greatest memorizer of his sunnah. and
narrations and he made dua for him and
he
tailored him in order to be able to
memorize and relate the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's words the
most and so most of what we get from Abi
are narrations he narrates to us I saw
the prophet do I heard him say etc
however on occasion
we do have instances where someone like
Abu will explain a verse from the Quran
now someone is memorized as
the majority of what he says with
respect to verses of the Quran. So he'll
mention a a verse and then he'll say
this is the meaning of this verse.
Where would we expect that he got this
understanding from?
From the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
Mostly
mostly. As a matter of fact, that goes
for the companions across the board.
Some scholars have even considered
that anything the companions say about a
verse
is
ex accepted as a narration from the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam because the
companions
were not people of opinions. They were
not people of I think and my opinion and
I believe and the way I see it and
etc. This kind of rhetoric was not in
their DNA. The companions
were most diligent in
transmitting narrations relating to the
what they saw, what they heard, what
they witnessed from the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. And so Abu Hurra
explains to us a verse and then in
another instance we see that this
explanation he got and he gave us is
actually a narration of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam verbatim.
And I bring this up because this is a
very dangerous slippery slope that some
modern speakers find themselves at.
And that is that they assume
that a verse of the Quran, if a
companion says this verse means the
following, that this is somehow just
that companion's opinion and it is okay
to contradict it. And that is a very
very dangerous argument. When a
companion explains a verse
and other companions do not disagree
with him,
this is articulating
an element or a dynamic of the verse
that was well accepted amongst the
companions. And where did the companions
get these understandings from? From the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. They
didn't
wonder about them and come up with their
own opinion.
They would hear verses, they would learn
them directly from the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and they would
learn their explanations from him as
well. So when a companion says this
verse means the following that is a red
line.
And so the scholars tell us that as long
as it is not a dis an issue where the
companions have differed on.
So one companion says this and another
says something contrary in the
explanation of the verse
to explain the verse
that will directly conflict with the
understanding of the companions
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
cited the companions
as being the yard stick for proper for
understanding, didn't he? In the Quran,
he says,
for
[Silence]
bey. for
we have a verse in where Allah cites the
companions's understanding
as being the proper yard stick of
understanding. Understanding the Quran
and Sunnah he says he says subhanahu wa
ta'ala that which means and so if they
meaning the people believe in what in
the way that you all have believed then
they have been become guided.
What do we understand this to mean? We
understand this to mean if they do not
believe in the way that you all have
believed then they have become what?
Misguided.
And the verses in this vein are many.
The point is is that when a companion
says this verse means the following and
other companions haven't differed with
him and it's not an issue that the
companions differed upon, this is a red
line. And the verse definitely means
this because they didn't just get this
from their minds or their opinions or
from rhetoric. Also I want to mention
one more thing that a lot of people
don't know about.
Every chain of narration to the book of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala hinges on
the Quran.
It fundamentally hinges on. He is one of
the five companions that the Quran's
recitation hinges on. So the same man
that is narrating these narrations is
the same man that narrates to us what
the Quran.
This is not just some guy. This is
not just somebody who learned the Quran
you know as a kid and this is a major
major companion of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. So Abuur tells us
that Allah says in a verse verse 110 in
Ali he says speaking to the companions
and by extension the Muslim to come you
all are the best of nations which has
been brought forth for the people. Many
of us have heard this verse before
right? You all are the best nation
that was brought forth for the people.
What does that mean? For the people. He
didn't say amongst the people. You're
the best nation that was brought forth
amongst the people. You are the best
nation for the people. Of all the
nations, how many nations were there?
Does anyone know?
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us that the number of nations are how
many?
No, not 72. That's the number of sex.
73. No, the number of nations is 70. You
are so close but so far at the same time
because you were in one subject and the
answer was in a completely different
universe. But very good.
70 nations.
70 nations. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that this nation is
the final and 70th nation amongst
humanity. And it in the mix the ratio of
this nation compared to the people that
have come before
is a white hair on the back of a of
a black bull.
Meaning on the day of judgment,
we all of us, the first of us and the
last of us, the jin of us and the and
the humans of us, we will be amongst the
nations
a black hair on the back of a white
bull. In one narration, he says a
white hair on the back of a black bull.
and another he says a black hair on
the back of a white bull. So you can see
that just this one hair in this sea of
humanity yet this nation is the best
nation.
Why is it the best nation? For many
reasons but in this verse Allah tells us
you all are the best nation for
humanity.
Then Allah explains that. He says
he says
you all are the best nation that was
brought up for the rest of humanity.
If you fulfill the role of commanding
the good, f forbidding the evil and
believing in Allah truly. Now Abu Huraya
shows us another aspect of this verse.
Another aspect that many of us maybe
would not see without his pointing it
out. He says
this verse means you all are the best of
people for the people.
You are the best of humanity for
humanity. You are the best of believers
for believers.
You are the best
of for. He says,
"This nation
literally and figuratively
brings people into Islam,
brings them from disbelief into Islam
with chains on their necks and takes
them into paradise."
Then he narrates in another narration,
Allah is astonished.
He is mesmerized
by a people who will enter paradise in
chains.
What does that mean? Enter paradise in
chains. will in Noi tells us that the
Muslim will have a lot of enemies and
when they clash with these enemies
they will take many of them as prisoners
of war as slaves etc and then those
people will choose to become Muslim. So
they will enter
into the midst of the Muslim in chains
and they will enter paradise in those
chains. This is very reminiscent of the
statement that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam made. He said in Muslim IM
Ahmed to a manlim become Muslim. The man
said,
he said, "I feel in my heart
turned off from becoming Muslim. I don't
want to." He said,
to the contrary even if you feel to the
contrary
because Islam is the truth even if a
person doesn't fancy it at the moment
and so we are the best of nations for
humanity
provided
we are ambassadors
and vanguards and ultimately martyrs
for and upon Islam.
The Muslim is different than the rest of
humanity.
We are not just, you know, give me my
toaster and my fancy radio and my nice
car. Don't rock the boat, okay? Let me
just live in my comfortable existence.
You do you. I'll do me. You know, I'll
refrain from double parking. I'll try
take the trash out on Wednesday nights.
I'll follow all the rules. Just pay me.
Don't. And I just want to enjoy myself.
This is not the narrative of the Muslim.
The Muslim is worth more than that. We
are not a passenger on this earth.
We are only the best of nations for
humanity
when we live for something.
If you do not have something that you
are ready to die for now,
you are living for nothing. That's the
truth. That's the reality of it. The
person who lives the most miserable life
is the one who is not seeking the most
honorable death.
To the point that the companions and the
after they saw how the prophet Muhammad
died, sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam he
was sick for a lot of time. How long was
he sick for before he died?
Anyone know
2 weeks
some narrations 15 days. What did he die
from? He died from poison.
Poisoning.
This is a terrible death. This is a
painful death. This is an agonizing
death to the point that his daughter saw
him
curled up from the pain enduring it and
she said
I see that you are in immense pain. He
said there's no pain upon your father
after this this
time after today. This is the last bit
of pain. When they saw how slow and
agonizing and difficult his pain was,
they held the belief that it was
shameful to die comfortably.
That the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
died in agony and I die comfortably.
No, they would seek the most violent
rageful death in martyrdom for the sake
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Because if
that is what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam went through in order to
meet his lord then I feel ashamed of
myself to meet him in comfort. Now
obviously we have different
battlefields.
There is a physical battlefield which is
not our battle here. Our battle here is
the battlefield of the heart. The
battlefield of knowledge. the
battlefield of learning and teaching and
preserving this revelation. Even if
we're unable to do something significant
with it today, we will at least
pass it on to the next generation.
Clean, pure, unadulterated.
We will end with a statement of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam
his followers. This was described as
[Silence]
they are described as a people whom
their gospel is in their hearts not in
the pages of a book.
the Quran
and
that Allah gave this ummah a book that
no amount of water will wash away.
When that book gathers dust on our
shelves,
we are
in a moment of shame before the altar of
Allah, before the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and our
ancestors. The world is waiting for us
to be great again. We had greatness. We
fumbled it along the way. A lot of us
were born into circumstances. But we can
change that right now. That's the beauty
of being human. You can choose. You are
not simply biology.
for
[Silence]
Subhanahu
He was